qué es una zona de exclusión aérea o una
no fly zone y por qué occidente se niega
a conceder la ucrania
muchísimas gracias primero hay que
hablar que no se trata de no estamos
hablando una zona exclusión aérea sino
que estamos hablando de imponer una zona
de exclusión aérea y esto implica que
hay que realizar patrullas constantes
sobre territorio ucraniano hay que
movilizar un gran número de aeronaves y
aunque un escenario idílico esto no
significa ser un enfrentamiento directo
con moscú podría significar una escalada
nuclear como ya hemos presenciado con la
señalización relativo al grado de alerta
de sus fuerzas estratégicas pero para
que la efectividad de la exclusión aérea
sea realmente efectiva deben derribarse
los aviones y helicópteros rusos en
vuelo no lo que evidentemente pues
implicaría un choque directo de la otan
con moscú a esto además hay que sumarle
la neutralización de las propias
amenazas a los aviones de la otan es
decir hay que localizar destruir los
sistemas anti arios que rusia tiene
desplegados ya no ya sea misiles de
tierra aire baterías antiaéreas radares
y no sólo eso sino también habría que
neutralizar los sistemas desplegados en
territorio ruso y bill o ruso por lo que
podrían suponer una amenaza no por lo
tanto estamos hablando de que esta
exclusión aérea hay que estar dispuestos
a disparar ya que se disparen como bien
ha afirmado el portavoz del pentágono
john kirby por eso los países de la otan
y de eeuu son tan reticentes a la
implementación de una descripción aérea
porque significaría una tercera guerra
mundial con con rusia y rusia ya
señalizado que esta tercera guerra
mundial sería de carácter nuclear
entonces podemos estar de acuerdo en que
una zona de exclusión aérea podría ser
considerada como un acto de guerra y así
le quiero preguntar hay posibilidad de
llegar a un punto medio como una zona de
exclusión limitada que también ha sido
propuesta
excelentes que también ha hablado no de
una zona de exclusión era limitada en la
zona occidental para favorecer los los
corredores humanitarios
pero yo creo que esto habría que verlo
muy bien sobre el papel cómo se va a
implementar porque el mínimo error ya
puede desencadenar una guerra conclusión
enfrentamiento directo de la otan por lo
tanto yo creo que sobre el papel ahora
mismo no está la zona de exclusión aérea
porque además dentro de los países de la
otan pues tenemos partidarios ya como
por ejemplo alemania donde marcar una
línea roja de que no habrá una zona de
exclusión aérea por lo tanto vamos a
hablar sobre otro tipo de medidas no
como ha
anunciado joe biden como por ejemplo el
suministro de aviones kamikazes ridgeley
no que sí que pueden suponer un game
changer para el ejército ucraniano bueno
y mire muy rápidamente en qué medida se
está librando esta guerra desde el aire
finalmente muchos misiles rusos son de
largo alcance pero lanzados desde tierra
nos quedan pocos segundos
si básicamente desde el punto de vista
aéreo rusia está sufriendo grandes
pérdidas hemos visto como los drones
ucranianos redactar tv2 están siendo
grandes y muy efectivos no hay por eso
creo que también eeuu apoyará en gran
medida la decisión de enviar trenes para
aumentar la capacidad en el aire del eje
de ucraniano